he is one of the best bantamweights on
the planet he's one of the best to ever
do it he recently retired and we had him
take an Uber from Orange County all the
way to Calabasas California it's TJ De
La Shaw on this week's food truck
Diaries and I'm feeding them quesadillas
let's go
[Music]
I need everything I get super thick boy
[Music]
what's up brother hanging out you're no
stranger to the food truck Diaries you
gotta love it dude come on eat some good
food yeah some [ __ ] yeah talk a little
Trash not too much trash maybe I'll go
too hard on people yeah uh you came out
some big news I was I I think going into
your fight against al Jermaine Sterling
I will I I did say this I I was trying
to tell people how it's a comeback story
and they should root for you and the
reasons why and Americans love a true
comeback story and I said I I have a
hunch and you and I didn't speak about
this as I do have a hunch if you were to
lose this one I think he's done just
because you look at the obstacle you
know that you'd have to get back to and
the chances you know so you look at your
career so going into this fight and for
those who don't know he announced he
retired if you live on Mars TJ retired
but um going into the fight was that did
you have that already kind of going
through your head like all right if this
doesn't go my way this is it uh not at
all man it wasn't it wasn't a thought in
my head I might expect to go out there
and win even with the injury that I had
I had like the utmost belief in myself
to get the job done
um you know it was a possibility to pop
I mean me and wife had talked like you
know I don't know how many are left you
know it could be my last one might not
be you know win or lose but I never
really had a set thing to retire and
even afterwards it's like [ __ ] away in
retiring yeah you know
um but I went and I had a shoulder
surgery four weeks ago and the doctor
just kind of like had like a raw
conversation with me he's like hey man
it's time to make a decision this is
your third shoulder surgery and last
three years you know he shoulders a lot
of water under the bridge
um it's got me like thinking about life
and my son and being able to like
actually be active with him and swing a
golf club with him and just live life
outside of fighting you know yeah I bet
I was it was a tough I mean still this
tough decision right I mean I haven't
even announced the Danny media Outlet oh
this is the first time I'm talking about
it so
um you know I wasn't expecting it for it
to be released the way it was you know I
told them like two days three days
before and then just taking off the
roster and everyone finds out yeah once
the UFC does that you know it's Off to
the Races yeah and I didn't know what to
expect so I kind of wanted to do it
myself but I didn't get that chance you
know yeah you want to you want to share
your story and your perspective of it
you know I think what's
kind of tough and heartbreaking being
your friend is you were compromised in
that fight it's not that aljo didn't do
a great job you know despite you having
you know uh one arm but I guess the
bummer for me as a fan a friend of yours
is like ah man he went out his last one
and he wasn't a full capacity like you
to see you know get to the title shot
and then you you know you have the one
shoulder and it's popping out during
Camp it's like ah man that I guess I I
guess I agree with this retirement yeah
you know but for me it's kind of
Bittersweet I mean it's for me too yeah
I mean like to go out like that to not
actually put a True Performance together
because I still believe I'm the best of
weight class I go out there healthy I
get that belt back and especially
against the fight like algeman who's
such a great matchup for me you know so
um hence why to continue to take the
fight even though I was injured you know
um and you got some pushback on that
right and but you got pushed back from
not from Fighters you got I mean I'm
sure some Fighters are going to talk to
this [ __ ] but he got pushed back from
media and fans and it's like oh you guys
have no clue of what professional
athletes deal with like the injuries of
course of course TJ thought he could win
even officials pop out of Camp it's like
yeah when people when I saw people were
upset like DJ was a refund I'm like you
guys are idiots yeah like you know me
Fighters and athletes and NFL players
and NBA players you've watched that did
pulled off and they had horrible
injuries yeah it's like that's what
makes you different than them I mean you
kind of have to believe that way you
gotta you got to have that mindset I
mean you got to be a [ __ ] straight
Citgo to get in there and do we do right
and if you if you don't then you know
you're making it to the top and how bad
was the shoulder going to Camp man
during Camp so I hurt my shoulder like
end of April beginning me as soon as
aljo called me out I knew the fight I
was getting ready
I mean I knew my shoulder's a little bit
messed up because I had some weakness in
it I thought it was a pinched nerve I
got an MRI done like in January because
I thought it was something in my neck I
can get fixed real quick but coming to
find out I had a torn supraspinatus and
infrasminius on my shoulder it was just
giving me weakness I figured this out
when I was doing Rehab on my knee I was
trying to lift weights upper body yeah
um but it was like whatever I've dealt
with shoulder injuries for since 2017 I
won World titles with it whatever no
stranger to the show yeah just just
forget about it break it down deep never
talk about it get a world title back you
know but
um I'd say end of April I was just
hitting mitts I had to go hit a big left
hook on the bag and I tweaked my
shoulder and it was like bad like I
couldn't hit Mitch with it couldn't
really move it but it was it got better
I went down got stem cells in Panama the
pain started to go away I couldn't
really fully use it I didn't have
external rotation I couldn't hold my arm
up like this it would be like outwards
right compromised I mean
far out from the fight but only striking
yeah it only is only messing with my
striking wasn't meth my grappling and
aljo was the one I was gonna fight so I
was like best case scenario I can
grapple like a [ __ ] I just
couldn't strike to my fullest but I was
fighting Sterling he's not dangerous on
his feet if I was fighting a guy like
Peter Yano would maybe second guessed it
right
um so it's something I was going into
and then I don't know it's five weeks
six weeks before the fight I got super
bad MRSA still same thing with the
shoulder the pain went away from stem
cells but it was only affecting my
striking so I was you know my right hand
Combos and kicks and actually was
sparring [ __ ] great and when you had
MRSA that's a form of stuff right yeah
so it's horrible stuff I assume we're on
antibiotics I was on like four different
antibiotics which would be terrible get
rid of it Achilles heel for cardio it's
awful cardio and just muscle develop
everything and so I just like I broke my
body down that way and I was grappling
doing Jiu Jitsu and I just looked at my
shoulder for the first time like five or
six weeks out and it popped back in it
was only out for a couple seconds and it
popped back in and so this guy you know
it'll be all right strengthen it up it'd
be fine but then it just kind of got
worse and worse as the time if I got
closer started cutting weight and I feel
like the body's just kind of like
breaking down and just got loose where
to where it actually popped out twice
while I was in Abu Dhabi getting ready
for the fight and that's when you're
training easy you're just trying to wait
like going through the motions and yeah
man do some grappling things with one
and I was in a head and armstroke he
went to go but me off and I couldn't
even post my arm out just like
dislocated out the back you know so
yeah I mean it was bad yeah man it was
bad bad it was bad but you're not gonna
turn out a title shot I'm 36 years old
yep I go and get surgery I'm out for a
year you know and it's like I know my
shoulder's bad and now I'm going through
meeting this doctor and he's telling me
like what if I retired and didn't give
myself that shot and the doctors told me
the same thing he's like man I don't
know if this is ever going to be the
same yeah and then I retire and didn't
get my shot yeah you know to our lease
like I go out there be a [ __ ] hero
just okay my shoulder get The Knockout
like we're on top of the world
especially anything can happen
especially the skill set you know I
co-signed that all day I appreciate it
any day of the week you know hell yeah
who says otherwise just doesn't know
Sports at the highest level I mean I
beat Dan Hagen which is a lot more
dangerous for a fighter on one leg one
leg completely blew my knee out and beat
him on one leg so right also in the back
of my mind's like you know what this is
something I just got to deal with I beat
um garbrandt twice with dislocated
shoulders I was dislocating my shoulders
and not fight Camp as well too maybe not
as bad but same issue now did anyone in
a camp ever say maybe
maybe take it down a notch in the camps
like you go hard in the paint you're
entersly known for it we had the same
coach in eastern bowling he said you
never see anybody train harder do you
think maybe that was kind of because
same thing happened to Cain Velasquez it
happened a lot of the AKA guys because
they when they went so hard in the paint
during training camps because their
bodies kind of
you know carry that level anymore it was
just too much yeah um who's that or what
do you think it is I think it's a
combination right I've just got some bad
shoulders to begin with and then once I
had the injury it was like you know how
easy can I go and find for a world title
you know so I had to spar and man I'm
telling you right now I was sparring so
[ __ ] because like because I only had one
Wing I had to like really figure out
what combos I could throw what angles I
could hit how I'm gonna move and I was
like so focused on on knowing I only had
one arm that I was on I was on point
dude my right hand was a [ __ ] laser
and I was doing great I was you know
competing with you know Cub Swanson and
Juan Archuleta these guys that are
killers in my weight class and I'm
getting the best of them and training
himself confident going in you got it
yeah you know I felt like I had it
against a guy like Al Jermaine too I
mean I feel like his striking to be
honest you know it's more embarrassing
to the Striking he's got to be on top
yeah but he's strong at what he does I
think for you too if you see in the
fight it wasn't something that aljo
threw you I mean you kind of kid you
went to go catch yourself on the octagon
floor and you went like this and you see
you just you can tell you like I can
style your face like ah [ __ ] like you
just see it goes and I was like oh damn
maybe it's the mouth you know 40 seconds
in the in the fight and I man I and I
and I game plan this out too should have
been a little bit better at it but uh I
shouldn't have been throwing kicks so
soon he caught he caught a push kick
which I was aiming down the middle this
is going to deter him from shooting
shots I saw Pedro Munoz hit him with a
good push kick down the middle to really
slowed him down and I was crushing it
and sparring so I was like real real
happy to start hitting that confident
about it a good a good weapon for me to
throw but he caught it hit a takedown
and posted my arm on the way down and
instantly just came out the top
um and so the whole rest of the round
I'm just like trying to it was like he
was on top hitting me and I was like
trying to pull my shoulder in the socket
or block punches I had to like decide
which one was more important you know so
I remember like trying to pull my
shoulder out he'd be punching me like
all right block so don't stop it and
then I'll go back to police here yeah
here pick your poison man yeah yet uh
who was it trying to put your uh
shoulder back in the socket between the
rounds uh Felipe de la Monica my Jiu
Jitsu coach she's the one that popped it
back in most of times during training
camp and there seems to be and Dana said
this uh maybe on the Patty podcast he
did but you know Yuri the light
heavyweight champion or formally because
he uh uh you know yeah but he was his
shoulder got really bad because I guess
he was training came out and his boys
are like oh dude you just pop it back in
it's like Mel Gibson from Lethal Weapon
and I guess they like once the doctor
got to it he's like well this is the
worst shoulder injury I've ever seen
because it wasn't bad at first but then
when his boys like jerking it back and
forth because they're not professionals
it just did way more damage so he's out
for a hot second you know but there's a
thing you know I've had my shoulder pop
down in football my buddies put it back
in so they're like never do that but
it's like I think that works more than
not you know where you just pop back in
you care about on your business business
but the on the other end of that with
year it's like pretty sure that
professionals handle it yeah there's a
right way to do it right and
unfortunately I knew how to do that
because it happened so many times and my
shoulders have just been bad I mean same
thing with Aaron Pico right they did
that's right they didn't expect it to
happen so they're just yanking on his
shoulder and Terry's living room a
little bit worse yeah
um so I game plan for it I had a meeting
with my doctor I was like hey will you
do a video of the best way for me to put
my shoulders socket oh it might happen
yeah and if this happened in Aaron
Pico's fight was before my fight yeah
actually I was like I should [ __ ] I
should game plan this on how to put it
back yeah let's not Bro Science my
shoulder yeah Dr Moore I film a video on
how to do it perfectly and so I you know
sent it to Felipe my Jiu Jitsu coach
okay that's smart so I had a game plan
going like this now most likely it was
gonna happen and he'd be able to pop it
back in
um and if you haven't dislocated your
shoulder so last thing you want to do is
like go to the doctor and wait three
hours with your shoulder down the socket
because it's so [ __ ] uncomfortable it
feels it hurts
you can see me in the corner uh at the
end between the first and second round
I'm like bent over and Felipe is trying
to pull it in yeah and then as soon as
it goes in it's just like an instant
relief like back yeah I'm like all right
I'm good yeah yeah the doctor comes over
like perfect timing too they put it in
the doctor came over I was like I'm good
doc don't worry about it he's like push
against my arms like see it's good let's
go okay I guess this works yeah let's
take a little break from chatting with
my boy TJ Dillashaw on this food truck
Diaries and he's talking about
retirement but I'm talking about
draftking Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner the NFL it's my go-to
for betting this NFL season especially
during the holidays man the same game
parlays are great my favorite part is
the easy and fast payouts they got the
best props out there and right now new
customers can bet just five buckaroos on
any NFL team to win their game and get
150 dollars in free bets if they do
check this out right now everyone can
earn up to 1 100 boost with DraftKings
stepped up same game parlays go to the
draftking Sportsbook app plays the same
game parlay and combine multiple bets
like which team will win player props
Point totals and so much more the more
legs that you add the bigger the Boost
the bigger shot to win big that's right
you got the Niners they're hot right now
Purdy the Mr Irrelevant six round draft
pick is Ballin he has too many weapons
at his disposal to lose don't bet on my
Broncos that's the best advice I can
give you do not bet on my Broncos I'm so
sorry Denver you get it download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app right now use
the code shop show schab show place a
five dollar bet on any NFL team to win
their game and get 150 dollars in free
bets if they do only at draftking
Sportsbook with code shop show minimum
age eligibility restrictions apply C
show notes for detail DraftKings from
code shop show on it supplements the
best supplements on planet freaking
Earth they got it all it's a company you
guys can trust and if you're hearing all
the talk around the water cooler about
these nootropics well on it makes not
only a nootropic but they make the best
new Trump talking about Alpha Brain
you've heard the one and only Joe Rogan
talk about nootropics and talk about
Alpha Brain he takes Alpha Brain system
says he helps him form better sentences
and I didn't take my Alpha Brain today
so you can tell I'm all over the place I
wish I had it if I did this would be way
smoother and way cooler it would be more
like Joe Rogan less like me take your
Alpha Brain if you want to save 10 off
you go to audit.com
FTD that stands for food truck Diaries
right so onnit.com FTD you save 10 off
not only Alpha Brain the best nootropic
on the planet they sold over 1 million
bottles and guess what if you don't like
it you get your money back no return
necessary keep the bottle we don't care
that's how sure on it is of their Alpha
Brain product but not only do you get 10
off Alpha Brain you get 10 off the
entire site protein bar cars Warrior
bars protein powder Krill oils
multivitamins shroom Tech they got it
all kettlebells steel Club maces workout
Gear streaming Fitness for you too so
don't wait till January first to get
your thick butt in shape start right now
and have the proper equipment the best
supplements on planet Earth the best
nootropic Alpha Brain on it.com FTD
tempestoff the entire freaking soda on
it audit.com FTD now let's get back to
the program so I mean just just like
with anything just like with any
technique or diet or weight cut you got
a game plan at all and so I just game
plan that's brilliant worst case
scenario and unfortunately I just got
your Jutsu coach was Bro Science and
like let me just jam it back in there
I've seen Lethal Weapon you know it's
like no dude you guys actually had a
plan for it and unfortunately somebody's
shoulder just blew out mine was so bad
that it was
it went back in pretty it would go in
and out that because it was something
ligaments I mean popped it so many times
yeah so I had the conversation with the
doctor and he kind of going over like
what was wrong my shoulder I had a fully
torn to my rotator custard fully torn
off the bone my super space my
infraspinatus my labrum was torn my
bicep tendon was torn and then also the
head of the humerus that goes into the
shoulder had like a had like a big dent
out of it just because I dislocated it
so many times and every time he
dislocated and put it back in it just
wears it out you know yeah that time
your body is just it's almost like
muscle memory which can keep pop it's
just gonna keep happening well it's not
round right that's not round yeah it's
kind of easy to pop out so you get done
with the fight you're back in the locker
room I'm sure you know you're really
upset how because the announcement came
quite some time after the fight like
what what went into that process
announcement of retirement yeah oh I
didn't retire until a ways after
the 30th of November yeah yeah so I had
surgery on the 10th and the doctor just
going into surgery real quick going to
surgery plan wasn't to retire no no not
really no I mean I didn't have no I
wasn't at all I mean I remember doing
interviews like this ain't the end of me
yep and I'm coming back
let me talk to the doctor and just
actually what's going on with my
shoulder and what the likelihood of it
actually healing to his fullest
um and then it's just kind of a Snowball
Effect too so I have my five-year-old
son the only fights he can really
remember are my last two fights
sandhagen I blow my knee out good fight
though so during fight Camp I'm I'm not
I'm not Daddy you know what I mean I am
and I'm not but I'm like in Colorado for
half the training camp I'm traveling I'm
gone he misses me when I'm gone I'm gone
at my fight I get back I'm on one leg
I'm laid up can't be playing with them
the way I'd like to and then my algro
fight right I'm out in Abu Dhabi for two
weeks come back get shoulder surgery so
he told me he's told me like probably a
good 10 times that I don't want you to
fight again nothing worse like I don't
want you I don't want you to eat twice
and every time you tell me he's like ah
[ __ ] you dig deep you know and then the
doctor's appointment tell me about my
shoulder
[ __ ] I don't know man it was it was
it still is tough I can tell you're
still struggling with it I yeah I uh how
old is your son he's five 25 in December
yeah that's when they start to realize
like oh Dad's leaving you know when
they're really little they really don't
know and they come back like there he is
they even know you're gone that long
yeah my son when I'm on tour like
they'll grab my luggage like Daddy don't
go it's like oh you're making so much
worse dude I'm only got three days like
I can't imagine what you're going
through yeah and if you give a [ __ ]
about being a dad it's super important
yeah you know it really is yeah yeah so
they're trying to grow our family you
know going through like fertility stuff
as well too so it's just just like you
said a snowball effect of reasons two
I'm being very successful in business
outside the cage yeah I want us to do it
outside so I don't have to fight I've
been saying that before this fight it's
like I didn't take the fight for the
paycheck I took the fight to be back on
top and to prove that I'm the best in
the world so I'm successful out of the
cage with business don't need the money
for fighting
um gotta you know I've built the Great
life for myself and my family and now
it's time to [ __ ] enjoy it you know
yeah when you retire I was like that
makes sense you know it's like I always
like when guys retire I hate when guys
stick around too long and then you know
we've seen this story before so I'd
rather a guy retire early and stick
around than they end up you know face
down ass up so also you're one of the
greatest ever do it you're one of the
best ever do it you know first bout Hall
of Famer so
it'd be nice to get the belt all good
you know all good it was a comeback
story you know you've done some insane
stuff you don't want the best to ever do
it so you know I think your son's proud
your family's proud so you don't have
much to prove I just know you and
there's this fire inside here and I
don't know what you're gonna do you know
what I'm saying like yeah a lot going on
but yeah you know you that you gotta you
gotta figure out something and maybe
maybe you're doing it maybe maybe it's
these businesses that you can put your
passionate you know you're passionate
about and the fire into that yeah yeah I
mean no matter what I'm gonna work my
ass off or I wouldn't know what it is
but it's just it's different it's
different right you know when you're a
world [ __ ] champion in something and
it's like you know in the way that I got
to take him from me and just not getting
it back it's gonna [ __ ] burn right
but the thing about me too when you're
not your retirement it's all uh some of
the comments from some of the other
fighters who you know saw through
whatever I'm just like still like really
no he's he's walking away man like you
don't have to worry about it yeah I
can't retire no it's like Jesus Christ
what's wrong I don't get it yeah I
figure must be like thank you TJ one of
us do it thank you so much with
something a lot the majority were but
then a few of them are just like really
yeah still yeah
you're still bitter that is what it is
man yeah you know you got to be jealous
of uh someone else's success so correct
well they're gonna be even more just I
would say this if they thought what you
did in the lockdown was good what do you
have going on outside that you're just
getting started so the haters need to
just sitting tight because you can get
better
I'll give you more to hate on yeah
appreciate it man well because you're
retired my man
um I have a Mexican food truck for you
I'm told the only thing they're gonna
give us is quesadillas with extra cheese
and meat so at least we don't have to
worry about cutting weight yes I can't
blame it on me dude so we're gonna try
and thicken you up make it a proper
thick boy so let me feed you and then
we'll get into the rest of the
interviews let's do it my man let's take
a little break from chatting about food
retirement and quesadillas with my boy
DJ Dillashaw because I'm here to talk to
you about a little product called happy
hippo that's right if you ever seen that
movie Limitless with Bradley Cooper
happy hippo kratom's not gonna make you
look like Bradley Cooper in that movie
but you can be thinking like him and
getting things done like them that's
right there's actually a little
something something that can help you
get close to that Limitless pill I'm
talking about happy hippo Kratom it's
safe it's great I used to Cherry uh High
concentrated shots before every show
before anything I do anything on stage
anything on TV anything on podcasting I
got happy hippo flowing through these
veins these thick veins it's happy hippo
baby it's the best focused product I've
ever used best part it's all natural so
if you don't know who to trust in this
Kratom game you can trust my friends at
happy hippo if you visit happyhippo.com
use the promo code thick boy you save 20
for life you can use as many times you
want share with your family your aunt
your classmates in college you share
with your gay Aunt Uncle we don't care
won't discriminate around here if you
want good Kratom you want the best
somebody can trust we're talking about
happy hippo happyhippo.com promo code
thick boy 20 off for life now let's get
back to the program oh my God you know I
had to do it
my women like my checks so make sure
that it's dead keep it real and make
them standard like comediate yeah
Standing Ovation they want me to do it
again I get it how you doing I'm good
how are you today uh we're good looking
for some quesadillas heard this the
place to come
oh what are you thinking steak pork
chicken I'm going up a store El Pastor
yeah Pastor please
for you and I'll do one al pastor in one
steak please that's some thick boys do
it right there dude you gotta get
indicted for this it's a celebration
retirement dude I gotta double up you
know what just give me any reason to
celebrate thanks so much appreciate you
were bigger than average you know that I
only roll with the Savages I just pulled
out of the back of the club make the
whip disappear like a magic trick how
could you even be mad at this I do not
see what the challenges I had to learn
how to balance it now so cold all right
man little uh a little quesadilla I
don't remember what we had on the last
food truck doesn't remember what we had
with TJ it was my food truck oh that's I
brought my own Food Truck Yeah clean
juice yeah that's right yeah how's that
going it's going good man
um we're taking over Southern California
right now we're building out uh we're
building out one in Dana Point right now
we have one here in Agoura Hills oh
really and then you guys had smoothies
and stuff too we got smoothies acai
bowls
um sandwiches wraps
um cold pressed juicing a little bit of
everything you know
make this better is you got the trough
in here too that do that this isn't a
sponsor that trough hot sauce it's hot
sauce with some little truffle some
truffle bag in there it's Truffle Pig
sweat
it is nice so good
are you worried about blowing up a
little bit you're not you know you're
not trained like you used to yeah yeah
but I've been jumping on the Peloton
doing some long rides and sweating at
least because I can't can't do cardio
right now either Dukes my shoulder I
can't run you know so I gotta be smart
about how I'm training it's the road
dude on that road bike that's what I get
yeah once I retire so I get hitting
those Road bites and but I'm in a sling
for the most part so if I crash on a
bike
that's the last thing I need to do is be
riding a road bike right now
so I've been riding the Peloton in the
garage at least you know because uh I
can't really fall off that [ __ ] yeah
it's a good workout though I'll tell you
it's starting to buy against Peloton but
uh wifey excited you retired it was kind
of like a Tom Brady situation like
Giselle was like it's either me or
football and he's like say last football
but it's gonna go terrible they're like
the worst team in the league no she
didn't play it was last night or
anything got smashed by the Niners
no she'd never give me an ultimatum like
that but you know she was definitely
looking forward to the time of when I
step away so that
I'm not in those training camps where
I'm not just like solely focused on my
next fight and watching tape and
training all day and then traveling for
Camp you know she gets her husband back
and a dad yeah exactly has a helping
hand but then is she uh I mean because
you're a busy dude outside dog that's
why it's always nice when guys do retire
early because it means you have
something to do the guys who stick
around way too long they don't have much
else going on it's like you know that
might hold myth at a UFC gym but you
know they're not that excited to get to
that part of their life
yeah you know so with you you got you
got the the greens Food Truck Yeah so I
got clean juice which has been doing
good work like we're area developer for
Southern California and I got some
exciting projects that I can't talk
about yet that's coming out with that
love it there will be you know
um and like retail retail stores and
stuff which has been pretty cool
um I'm a part of a company called zuke
it's a cannabis company we have a farm
up in Northern California and we're
spreading uh dispensaries down here in
Southern California
um
those are like the big two projects I
got going on right now that are taking a
lot of my time obviously just though if
you list off like 10 things like all
right well let's dial it in a little bit
well the area develops gonna be big boys
yeah yeah well the area development of
Southern California is Big right open up
brick and mortars and things in Southern
California but then the retail side of
it's even bigger and that's going to be
a whole other side of us uh spreading
spreading the whole nation so it's
exciting and that that one to me is like
taking most of my time right now don't
call me crazy but
say a year from now that shoulder's
feeling good got home with the wife
kiddos you turn on UFC 99 or where the
hell they're going to be on and you're
seeing the bantamweight Championship
going down like you look at your wife
like I feel like you can beat these guys
you don't think you ever
have that itch come back
because it's it's a thing right guys
retiring and like you know what I'm not
done yet we'll see man we'll see how
successful things turn out for me
outside the cage and just how busy I am
and just uh that'd be a good problem to
have what life looks like you know
because I might be so busy that
you know I'm already in kind of that
busy where I don't have time to even
come back even when I did come back and
like had to like put business in the
back to deal with the fight it's tough
you know it was uh
because that business is going to pay me
for the rest of my life for this fight's
only going to pay me now so short term
but you know when I was eight weeks out
I was like all right sorry guys you
ain't gonna get a hold of me I'm not
dealing with anything business related
unless it's got to do with my fight you
know so I'm sure they understood that
they did yeah and you you leave the
division and it's in an interesting spot
because you know bandwid division is
pretty stacked you know so you got Al
Jermaine the champ obviously and then
they announced he's gonna fight uh Henry
sehudo who's coming out of retirement to
do that fight thoughts on on that fight
I think sudo wins I do man I think he's
uh let's take a picture against him yeah
it is it's tough big against him and
he's just um I think he's sharper on the
feet I don't think alja is gonna build
out wrestling you know
um I just got the better Jets but I
don't think he's gonna be able to like
take advantage of that because of the
wrestling and then sudo's really good at
distance control with like that like
karate style base you know he's pretty
smart what about Ring Russ but he's been
in the gym so much I feel like he's
always coaching and helping guys out I
agree he retired and I knew was like a
play to try to get more money right and
now he's back at the right time I think
it's a great fight for him
he's been just constantly in the gym
helping people out training for their
fights
um like when I was on my suspension I
was helping one or July to get in for
his fight so I didn't feel like ring
rust was there you know because yeah
you're still involved and thinking about
it yeah I wouldn't let her and if you're
smart if he's coming back he's gonna do
a couple camps he's not gonna just do
one camp for this fight he'll probably
do a test Camp get his body into shape
and get down to weight and then one of
the smartest ever do it yeah and that's
that I think one of his biggest assets
is how well he uses what tools he has
yeah and integrating those into his game
plan and just mentally he's as tough as
they come he's Olympic [ __ ] Champion
yeah dude you know like two Division
champion yeah any uh
when you look back on your career I mean
obviously I think I know the answer but
any regrets 10 25 100 I mean that's like
the biggest regret I have right now is
cutting 25s yeah
and just like not only just getting in
trouble just what I did to my body you
know because like everyone's seen that I
got in trouble and it got suspended but
dude like the six months after that of
me like bouncing back from that weight
cut and just destroy my metabolism
looked like she had went through surgery
so like that was hard on me I was hard
on my hormones it's hard on everything
man that's yeah that's probably the one
kind of you look at your resume that's
why I'm like no I probably shouldn't
have done that yeah especially just uh
wear and tear on your body which I'm
sure doesn't you know right it's not the
reason you're injured but it didn't help
no definitely didn't think your body of
all those nutrients and you fell into
that weight I wouldn't have gotten in
trouble none of that [ __ ] would have
happened right so that would have been a
big difference as well so yeah that's my
biggest regret for sure is trying to go
down to 25s I should
the same thing is like why I feel like I
took this fight this last time too right
like you just have the ultimate belief
and to go like when I put a goal in my
head I'm going to work my [ __ ] ass
off toilet get it done when I said I'm
gonna be double Cham going down 25s he's
like I'm getting it done you know and
that's what I said I'm thinking about it
well I don't think get to your level and
your tenacity you know that Mamba
mentality without you know obviously
it's the impossible you're trying to do
so that's what it takes yeah it gets you
into trouble sometimes yeah everyone's
just some trouble with that mentality
everybody doesn't matter who you are
yeah and if you see if you're a guy that
says you haven't made a mistake I don't
[ __ ] trust you then anyways
it's like that billionaire got busted
the weird whatever guy the crypto Guy
where he's in oh that's right
billionaire and he's in sandals and
drove a Prius like I don't you know I'm
not about money I'm like I do not trust
that guy any faster yeah the billionaire
and sandals and the Prius who are you
doing it for dude I wasn't buying that
weird
um
um no I feel you
but uh outside that nothing I mean you
look at your career it's been a great
run man yeah it's been it's been great
it really has I mean like I said I built
a great life for myself
and I've you know accomplished
everything that I've wanted to right
obviously there's always more there's
always more you can do but I've done it
right so I've built this great life
and the reason why I'm stepping away is
because it is time to enjoy it I don't
want to be the guy that just keeps going
after it and then you know it's too late
to actually enjoy what I've built you
know it grows so fast it's it's an
apartment like I could freeze them I
know it's heartbreaking I know man and
it's like you don't realize how fast
time goes by until you have a kid
because everyone will say like oh enjoy
this time it goes by so fast but then
when you have a kid it just happens
right in front of your face you know
like you see your career go by and I
feel like it took forever but when I
watched my son go from being a baby to
five years old it's [ __ ] absurd awful
yeah you don't miss out on that yeah
um you tell me if I'm off on this but
I'll tell you what in again you know off
the Conor gets a lot of [ __ ] for some of
the Antics he does so Connor fights
Dustin pore
blows his knee out whatever
oh no breaks his leg in half breaks his
legging out basically does that Anderson
sailboat snap so he does all that so
yeah his leg falls off yeah his leg
falls off then he gets out of it you saw
the testing he's on his yacht and his
Gucci stuff doing his thing everyone's
up in arms about like this isn't fair
and I'm going that's exactly what I
would do the only guys the best way to
do it is by taking you know and people
like go steroids no you're talking about
peptides and HH to speed the body to
recovery at his age to get back to a
fighting shape you know I don't have an
issue with it at all when guys are that
injured I hate to tell you that's what a
lot of guys do in the offseason other
sports that's how they come back so fast
we don't have an off season yeah we
don't get enough season we're testing
365 days a year you don't get time to
heal you don't get you know you don't
get these down times the guys in movies
he's doing all this [ __ ] his legs broken
in half and even if he were to take
steroids to recover himself he can't
compete with it in his system so he's
not going to have any kind of Advantage
from taking what he's taking all he's
doing is healing yeah you know if you're
telling me that a guy can't heal is
going to make not only himself but the
UFC hundreds of millions of dollars that
makes no sense not though that's why I
think the UFC hasn't really common like
yeah you know the honor well he's not
doing anything wrong you know he's not
fighting when he fights he'll be tested
and that'll be of his system yeah I mean
if there's a guy's retire and I had to
fight him he's not I know he's not
fighting when he's on the [ __ ] so it's
whatever you know if he can heal the
right way he actually has a career
because I mean do you break your leg
like that you might not ever come back
you know
never the same yeah only the biggest
Cash Cow I'm sure you have so he's like
do what you got to do on that yacht
daddy you know I would do the same thing
yeah I gotta I gotta assume you're
relieved you thought it was not coming
around anymore were they just constantly
since I'm one of the I'm the second most
tested athlete in the UFC roster Casa's
got me beat yeah but lacosta's got me
beat man this is funny with it it is man
well you finally like turned a new leaf
with it right because that I never
thought the casa was funny in the past
you know but then he just like decided
to like run with it and I think it's
pretty [ __ ] funny yeah it was like
kind of this mean troll at first but
then he started to get more creative and
like funny about it that's hilarious
yeah I like just give him some [ __ ] yeah
like poke fun like here's my secret
sauce you know it's like cranberry juice
whatever yeah yeah he's fighting with it
but yeah that usada that exhaust right
coming early in the mornings at six
o'clock in the morning
every time my wife is saying like every
time we've gone on vacation or went and
done something they've always showed up
I go to Columbia to get stem cells they
show up we go on vacation somewhere they
show up they think that like you're like
changing your whereabouts like sneak
something by them but
yeah no matter where you know I bet
you're excited to get done with that man
it's like my son's so used to it too
like see people show up to our houses
what's up Gary dad Gary's here he'll
like answer the door again
Dad Gary
yo you're five
he's used to like these people coming
over hanging out my house for like two
hours drug testing because they'll show
up and like I've just pissed or I just
took a [ __ ] right let's get out of jail
yeah I gotta wait I gotta wait wait yeah
he's gonna be gay but even if I have
something to do they'll follow me if I
gotta go to practice they'll follow me
to practice like
they're there until you like have to go
to the bathroom again you know so yeah
it'll definitely be nice enough to have
to deal with that but I definitely
didn't have any like that wasn't that's
a deciding factor no just more annoying
than anything it was funny like I was on
the verge of like deciding to
retire not after talking to the doctor
and you know my son told me weighing in
like he did not want me to fight my you
know my wife's you know over just the
the drama that comes with fighting right
so ever since I left exhausted alpha
male yeah it's just been a [ __ ]
exhausting [ __ ] show you know what I
mean just and so that that part will be
nice of it as well too and then I don't
know we were doing something getting
ready for Christmas or doing something
and they show up we're supposed to go
out to dinner it's like you got to be
[ __ ] kidding me you know it's like
all right maybe I should just retire
yeah you're dealing with this [ __ ] you
guys aren't helping this yeah they're
helping my decision it's interesting and
you know it's just the the culture and
climate we live in because UFC's a newer
one of the big five Professor Sports is
the newest one so the birth of the UFC
and mixed martial arts was on social
media and chair dog on The Forum so it
does build this like toxic culture so
I'll see the treatment you know when
after the cejudo fight I get it a little
bit right yeah but to even to this point
now like you said when you're not your
retirement guys are still going at it
I'm like really and so I think maybe I'm
defensively because I'm a guy who gets a
lot of hate too right but I'm 39 years
old I I I understand that I can deal
with it but when I see it the the hate
gun pointing towards a young kid like
Patty pamlett you look at what's going
on with him and the the way the MMA
meetings portraying it like oh biggest
robbery in UFC history and is he the
most overrated fighter of all time is it
him or
you know is it Paige VanZant like it's
just like holy [ __ ] man this kid's 27
years old trying to live his dream he
has nothing to do with the judging he
has nothing to do with it people have to
judges don't be mad at Patty yeah I just
see it going down this toxic Road I'm
like oh you guys have no idea what that
kid has to deal with yeah because you
guys paint this nasty nasty narrative
model
so yeah I've been on both sides of it
right because I've been I feel like one
of those haters in the past because I
was world champion I was [ __ ] do what
I was supposed to do I was working my
ass off then you see this guy [ __ ]
Conor McGregor coming to the scene right
like just sprung under the scene she's
just backing him paying him a bunch of
money this and that's like [ __ ] this guy
right it's like you instantly want to
hate on him yeah and then um you know
being on the other side of it and I was
like
being being hated or even just now
putting in all the work of all the so
having to go through the drama of
leaving alpha male or fighting guard
brand going through all that stuff
that's when I got paid the most
you start to understand it and and yes
you do feel bad for the piglets right
because yeah I didn't watch the fight
but you read on Instagram or like any of
these um uh media coverages they're like
the biggest [ __ ] robbery ever and
then I hear talk to someone else is like
I really wasn't that bad you know what
the problem is is because we live in
like a digital social media world so
maybe the majority of the people you
know a good amount of people watch it
but not as many people are going to see
that post from whatever insert whatever
journalists or insert whatever big MMA
social media handle people more people
can see that than about the pay-per-view
so that narrative is you know biggest
robbery of all time Patty's awful he's
not worth the money well that that then
that just becomes normalized and it's
like oh there's patties and you're
you're tearing down this stuff so much
potential he's gonna make so much more
money because of it though yeah you're
right I mean like the Floyd Mayweather
effect we're paying to see him win or
lose yeah yeah they're gonna hate him
for that and they're gonna like talk
[ __ ] about him getting hooked up or
UFC's favorite little boy then they're
going to want to watch him lose and he's
going to get paid more yeah I think one
of the reasons I started to think about
it because I was doing shop show today I
was like like I've had Patty on here you
know I've had everybody on here he's one
of my favorite people like he had so
much energy
he's a guy you just you almost got to
find a way to get in he'll just he's a
guy when he's doing like his thing oh
look he'll be like which one's my camera
and he'll do it at the camera like this
is a WWE guy like he just knows he's
just entertaining he checks every box
um so I was like man he has so much
light and he's a positive person
obviously he has his beast beef with air
and stuff like that and like I just
don't get it and it's not his fault that
the judges gave it to him and you know
he has no control of that then I I think
a bit of it that's really pissing people
off is a the judge's decision which he
has nothing to do with but that's just
the world we live in then B he did that
podcast where he's like mates with Dana
White it's like when your mates with the
warden of the prison the other prisoners
aren't gonna dig that you know being
special treatment you're getting an
extra you know Twinkie he's giving you a
nice bad you know the other inmates are
gonna [ __ ] hate you man yeah some
people like that's unfair you know well
it's like exactly what I was saying I
was hating on Connor when he came on the
scene yeah right but then you realize
when you're on the other side of it how
much work actually goes into
[ __ ] it's exhausting you know
like I actually wouldn't want to be that
you know because I mean yeah there's a
[ __ ] start on the money all that [ __ ]
it comes with it but it's like bro that
[ __ ] never gets a day off like
he's stacked you know so the pen was
going to work his way up to that I mean
it takes a lot of work yeah I think with
uh Patty I'd like to see what how you
assess his skill set but to me it's like
the his notoriety and his Fame has
surpassed his his skill set 100 and I
think I do think Patty has the ability
to be world champion but you got to give
him time and when they compare him to
Conor McGregor he's not Conor what
Connor did was very special he's one of
one but for Patty if you just give the
guy time to get to where you guys put
him in his Fame he'll get there but
you're you're gonna miss out on a great
thing if you want to tear this Liverpool
star down before he even get started man
because there's things out reaching
where he's at skill sets so you'll see
has to do a good job pairing him up for
his next fight was that his third UFC
fight
uh the uh those that's fourth or third
which is like a certain things because
either two in England then one of the
the then maybe it's Fourth right yeah
they could yeah because you got to go
back and look at the most most UFC
fighters when they have three UFC fights
you know they're fighting guys that are
on their level but he's so hyped up
they're expecting to fight a top 15 guy
already but it's like why he's only he's
only his third UFC fights not a Sprint
man for him it's just like slow down
dude because
almost finished with this classic
episode of food truck Dodge with TJ
dillash album before we end I gotta let
you guys know we gotta take a little
break I gotta live I Gotta Give TJ
dilshaw a little break all right he
wants to finish his quesadilla I want to
talk to you about Rogue that's right if
you watch any show I do food truck
Diaries cop asks this fight companion
Fight Night flashback fighting the kid
golden hour
I do too many shows it's a Shop show
whatever I'm doing you'll notice one
product and one product in every single
show it's in my mouth but it's also
usually on the desk we're talking about
Rogue talking about Rogue nicotine and I
reached out to my friends at Rogan I
said hey you know I use it please be
part of the program because I swear by
this product it's the only way I get my
nicotine is through their pouches but
they don't just have pouches they have
lozengers they got freaking gum they got
it all man they got tablets for you so
if you don't want the pouches which you
should if you don't there's other ways
Los Angeles tablets gum they got it all
my favorite flavor right now is the
Apple but they also got the lemon honey
drop which I really dig right now I like
to switch throughout the day green
yellow green yellow they got freaking
peppermint Wintergreen Berry the flavor
is fantastic that's why I only use rogue
rogue destroys anything else out on the
market there's nothing like Rogue
especially with the the six milligram
they have three and six but I use six
because you know
I live rough all right so get the six
milligram if you're gonna be like your
boy here all right I take it anywhere I
want flights the airport green rooms
podcast Studios at home in the gym
riding my bike it goes everywhere with
me there's no restrictions so Rogue is
my go-to source for nicotine all right
um if you want to try the pouches like
your boy here or the gums tablets every
nicotine go to Rogue nicotine.com use
the code rogue20 that's r-o-g-u-e 20 for
twimps off your entire order again
that's Rogue 20 for 20 off your entire
order
Rogue nictine is the best nicotine on
the planet we're talking about Rogue
Daddy all right under eight sales
prohibited warning this product contains
nicotine nicotine is addictive chemical
for more information visit
roguenicketing.com
Rogue get you some now let's get back to
the program they've done that with sugar
sugar Sean yeah yeah sugar Sugar's done
a great job man I mean they didn't I
mean the biggest promoted guy in 135s
you know yeah and I think
with sugar they did they took the time
with them then eventually you know they
gave him the Pedro Munoz they give them
the Cheeto veras and I think eventually
UFC's like all right we've built this
star we support them now [ __ ] or get off
the pot and it's like boom Peter Young
oh [ __ ] you guys ain't messing around I
know but you know you did however people
want to say he did pass that test you
know so now he's sitting there the
number one you know in the world you
know so I just you know with the hate
with Patty I guess you know that's right
the guys who are hate the most make the
most money yeah I mean but the reason
why they're hated the most is because
most of it is jealousy right I mean most
of it's jealousy and hate like all the
guys that are hating on Conor for doing
what he's doing now too are most of the
guys that have never made it you know
there's never guys that have made it
been Champions what they've done that
you don't see them come out and talking
[ __ ] about what he's doing you know you
don't see Izzy or tomorrow yeah exactly
right so most of the guys that like want
to give him an excuse of why they didn't
make it yeah you know so you just got to
remember all that [ __ ] when it comes
with it but But ultimately it put it
lines your pockets so that's a good
point you can only complain you can only
complain too much about the hate being
brought your way because it has been
exhausting for you looking back on your
career like when you're going through
that I just remember it's like in every
headline you know I was like doing the
show
it was the exhausting I don't know what
the I don't want to get into it with
alpha male and all that stuff and then I
remember forget who was wanting to come
out Maestro I'm like bro I'm not Andy
Cohen this isn't isn't real housewives
of UFC I'm not I'm not into this whole
thing yeah I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened I'm friends with TJ so I'm not
definitely not giving you a platform to
talk here yeah
but for you like it has to be exhausting
dealing with that all the time like
especially before a fight it's like oh
God I feel like a lot so
I love MMA I love the fighting right
I've learned uh just like a little bit
of the business a little bit and I think
it all started
when I left alpha male right because I
had like homeboys buddies best friends
you know brothers and then just kind of
[ __ ] crashes and all the drama
happens right it like ruins a lot of
people and I'm not I'm not a guy that's
like really into that there's guys that
come in like the Patty Plymouth uh Conor
McGregor's that are into that [ __ ]
they're willing to do it like yeah
exactly sugar I wasn't into that [ __ ]
right I just got to the top because I
was good correct and then when the
[ __ ] all the drama happened it kind
of like took a lot of Sail Out of the
Winds of like enjoying fight weeks or
going to the fights or being involved
because it's so no matter what you say
it's energy you're putting this energy
into that and you're thinking about it
you know you're like yeah god dude I
just want to fight man yeah but I
started getting paid more
there's more attention more eyeballs on
you
um either because they hate you or they
want to see the drama they want to see
the car crash they want to see the
[ __ ] so you're going to get paid
more because of it right the budgets
gravitate towards that like drama right
and it does take a lot of [ __ ] work
so you know it's it's valid you're
getting paid for a reason because you're
getting them eyeballs you know you're
getting them views yeah so by you having
the alpha male guys on probably helped
you out right but you didn't want to do
it because of friendship stuff but
ultimately it would have helped out the
show or eyeballs and viewership you know
you know I'm definitely not retiring or
anything like that from Comedy or
podcasting but
you know I look back on things I was
talking to account about this and Theo
and Lee and some of my boys about it
like I just never like and there's been
a you know I have a million people come
at me don't like me for whatever reason
and they'll do stuff on their show or
you know fighter or journalists talk
stuff about me I've just never been the
guy to and I know would get views I know
people like it I just I just don't like
putting that energy out into the
universe you're taking it home no I
can't you're gonna take the energy home
with you I can't yeah I just can't I
think that's been a really hard part for
me is like all the [ __ ] dealing with
like the drama and whatnot is taking it
home right like trying to be a different
person at home impossible then with
everything else that's going on it's
like you're that shit's gonna put you in
a bad mood then you're going home to
this like wonderful child that just
wants you to be dad and be cool and hang
out and play [ __ ] Legos and you're
thinking about fighting and drama and
trying to try you're right son listen so
there's this there's this form like what
like Billy seven seven nine said this
he's like what the hell is happening
right now and Dad's stressed out bro
that's funny you bring it up because
like just happened like not too long ago
like me being all stressed out because
like my retirement got announced without
even like getting an announce it myself
that pissed me off and like I'm like in
a bad mood he's like dado why your voice
so grumpy it's like oh I'm sorry buddy
it's like I'm just dealing with I like
trying to explain like Instagram or
media to him like people talking [ __ ]
about my job and it's like it's like I
don't understand he's like why do you I
look when they just put in perspective
like why do you care y'all it's a good
point you're right five you got you
almost piss your pants over excitement
over the bubbles I need to be more like
this kid you know like kids don't give
up it gives you perspective though like
you're doing your idea with my share of
drama and it'll get through I'm like oh
and they walk home and they're just like
why am I giving this attention yeah you
know he's like who care your son's like
I don't give a [ __ ] dude yeah yeah I
seriously like just so you started
saying just happened the other day you
know yeah with the retirement thing you
know I oh I don't know who your
management is but it's almost like like
I would prefer you come out and announce
it yourself on your platform and say
what you want to say then tell the let
the UFC find out you're tired yeah I
guess so yeah
yeah but I didn't ask my major I just
did it you know what I mean like I went
and saw the doctor I was like with my
son just everything going on and just
like [ __ ] this I'm done you know and so
it's like uh wrote a letter to uh Hunter
and told him like Hey man thank you for
what you've done for the support and the
platform you've given me and the name
I've been able to build because of it
but it's just too much I'm out right now
and it was cool marketing team forward
that's how that goes I mean the roster
yeah it wasn't even like they didn't
announce it I was retiring it was the UC
just took me off I'm ranked number what
one or two yeah and then I'm just off
the rankings you got you got those
journalists like those MMA guys like in
the garage like
no it's like yeah and then it all
happened just a [ __ ] Whirlwind right
away so fast like I didn't even I don't
remember what I was doing but I would go
back to my phone it's just [ __ ]
messages after messages I wanted to do
interviews and this I'm like nope turn
my [ __ ] phone off yeah get away from
it yeah yeah so this is my first my
first time talking about uh retirement
here brother I support you and
appreciate it um whatever you want to do
a year from now you're the shoulders
feeling froggy let's run it back and
then uh otherwise just keep building
that Empire man and doing what's the
plan being the best dad you can and [ __ ]
everybody else dude that's all you can
do that's all you can do that's my life
yeah it's gonna be a five-year-old yeah
you want some advice in life just be a
fighter yeah be a five-year-old forget
everyone else
that's what my five-year-old does but
before we get you out of here dude we
give every guest a pair of kicks my boys
oh no way oh dude we got to get you some
kicks dog now you retired too it's even
got my size children's five they're size
17. oh [ __ ] no way dudes our uh I mean I
can't give your Legend here those are
Jordans are legendary dude this is
[ __ ] happy you got it brother yeah I
really appreciate it yeah you've been so
supportive of me man and you know
[ __ ] the guy dude and I'm proud of
you brother I'm I'm you know I'm excited
that you retired so I'm excited to see
what you do next man appreciate it
fighting as much as you did that's a
chapter you know that's one or two
chapters in TJ dillashaw's book because
I don't think athletes realize that like
it's a small chapter don't Define who TJ
is yeah you know like now what you go on
and do outside of this like this is just
like how old are you
um 36. the week 37 February it's like
that's a short chapter dude it's like
time to get going it's hard to remind
yourself of that [ __ ] though right
because that's like all I've identified
as right TJ little show world champion
teacher dual show UFC world champion it
was like that's what I built my
businesses around too I mean UFC's
giving me a great platform to build my
name and not build businesses off of it
but it's like that's always what I
identified as right and that's the
problem yeah that's the problem whether
it's football whatever it is it's like
they they think that their identity of
things just tied up with I'm a fighter
I'm a fight I've never felt that way so
I went into business or comedy
podcasting I never felt that way no no
you guys label me that I think I'm all
this other stuff cool that's fine if you
want to say that but I'm over here man
yeah I think you do the same thing and
bring that same passion tenacion's
business world and they better watch out
man [ __ ] egg dude appreciate it
brother I appreciate it TJ Dillashaw
everybody
if you're into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one
[Music]
I need everything I get super thick boy